anderson's water district is getting  bigger today the city officially opened  a new stretch of water street from warm  springs way out to boulder highway  the idea is to link the cadence master  plan community with  the water street district  this is just a great day for henderson  it creates  accessibility and connection for the  residents of cadence  but it also opens this area up so as  people want to come down  on water street and enjoy the breweries  and restaurants and businesses  it creates a better access as well now  the mayor says projects just like this  really create access for residents and  also  increase that connectivity to different  areas to and from downtown henderson